Esto ucraniana no puede contener las
lágrimas y observa con incredulidad las
banderas de su país son de árabe a su
alrededor aquí en balaclia las fuerzas
ucranianas han expulsado al ejército
Ruso y un vehículo de Infantería
atravesado en la plaza con una bandera
ucraniana para ser sincera se me paró el
corazón y empecé a llorar no podía
creerlo me acerqué a ellos y les
pregunté si podía tocarlos sabíamos que
nuestra ciudad era imposible de tomar
vivalacles una de las muchas localidades
en el noreste cercanas a la estratégica
harkif que han vuelto a estar bajo el
control de Ucrania que celebra los
éxitos cosechados en su contraofensiva
en más de seis meses de ocupación rusa
los residentes sobrevivieron sin
electricidad agua potable con mucho
miedo ahora reciben la ayuda humanitaria
de kiev
cómo crees que es vivir bajo la
ocupación teníamos miedo de todo no
salíamos del sótano cuando había
tranquilidad salíamos a gatas para comer
e ir al baño vivíamos con miedo porque
los rusos ponían bol si se llevaban a la
gente para torturarlas
las marcas de los combates se aprecian
En los edificios destruidos y en los
restos de munición y vehículos militares
que el ejército de Moscú dejó atrás en
su retirada pero el horror también se
refleja la prisión de la ciudad donde
los rusos se encerraban y torturaban a
la población la gente hizo marcas en las
paredes de cuantos días pasaron aquí
como ves hay marcas en esta pared artem
fue sometido a vejaciones luego de que
los rusos se encontraron una fotografía
de su hermano vestidos de militar
me llevaron una celda de la prisión me
dieron dos cables había un mecanismo que
pasaba más electricidad Cuanto más lo
girabas el soldado ruso lo giró cada vez
más rápido diciendo si lo sueltas estás
acabado
Mientras tanto los combates continúan en
otras partes de la región con kiev
decidido a tomarse el control total de
la región de harkif y más allá todos los
territorios ocupados por el